hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga today we're going to be
exploring the ship madness that his mob
psycho 100 and why it is most certainly
worth investing your time into it just
to give you a quick idea of what it's
about we'll start with the basic premise
which is as follows she gave Kai Yama is
an average middle school boy nicknamed
mob literally meaning background
character for lacking any sense of
presence although he looks like an
inconspicuous person he is in fact a
powerful ESPA with immense psychic power
to keep him from losing control of this
power he constantly lives a life under
emotional shackle in order to help him
learn how to control his abilities mod
works as an assistant to conman
reagan-era taka
a self-proclaimed psychic mob bonds to
live a normal life just like those
around him but barrage of trouble keeps
coming after him with his supposed
emotions growing inside mob little by
little his power threatens to break
through its limits as he eventually
encounters other Spurs like the claws
and that little synopsis said does not
even come close to covering the
incredibly crazy world that is mob
psycho 100 so initially you'll probably
have noticed some artistic similarities
to one punch man which makes a lot of
sense because both series were web
comics created by one and I'll just say
immediately if you enjoyed one punch man
you will love mob psycho 100 no
questions asked this series very much
carries that same delicately balanced
tone of incredibly goofy comedy mixed
with heightened drama and absolutely
phenomenal action however on top of all
of that this series really takes the
general concept of just weird to the
next level and while I really love that
I will say that it can be in a quiet
taste and you may not be entirely
satisfied by the first couple of
episodes which follow a more slice of
life format before really kicking into
some seriously awesome Esper story and
at the helm of everything is generic
background looking character mob who
holds the entire series together through
being the definition of chill his
calmness and ability to take on
seemingly any situation is integral in
keeping the series grounded because it
does get incredibly crazy at times but
having mob stops it all from moving too
far into the realm of abstract and mob
is just a fantastic character in his own
right as well this is not something that
will become apparent immediately but mob
has a serious character arc going
through this short but sweet story and
it's a big WOW moment when you look back
on where he came from
after seeing where he ends up he's far
from the emotionless derp he appears to
be and it was a pleasure to follow his
journey of change however my personal
favorite character in the series would
have to be breakin one of our secondary
protagonists from the very first episode
this man is pure hilarity and a lot of
that comes from the brilliant vocal
performance of takahiro sakurai
a man
I know best Isuzu crew from koteas and
my god is this a different role Regan is
a true force to behold on screen
confidently weaving his way around the
world of psychic powers that he has no
business being in whatsoever and just
like mob he's not a one-note character
either and is capable of superb drama
and strangely enough given that he is
into nespa even the odd dose of action
and the rest of the cast really do
embody that as well because no one is
really who they seem upon being
introduced mob psycho 100 really enjoys
playing with anime tropes specifically
in regards to characterization and as a
result you can never really predict the
twists and turns of certain individuals
will take and one really simple example
of this would be very early on in the
series where we have a super
intimidating group of muscle heads
introduced known as the body Improvement
Club and they're introduced to us under
antagonistic circumstances as well so
the expectation is that they're going to
be your typical boneheaded selfish dicks
but then that is immediately dispelled
and they become some of the nicest and
most amazing characters who you really
root for and love seeing on screen but
things do go the other way around as
well and at times certain characters who
we've previously thought of as
quote-unquote good guys can turn on us
but the key aspect of all of this is
that mump psycho 100 really highlights
what it is to be human people make
mistakes and some of our beloved
characters can find themselves in the
wrong and some of our most antagonistic
forces can come to realize their
mistakes and begin a path of redemption
there is never any true force of good or
evil at player mob psycho 100 everyone
is just human and that is endlessly
fascinating but of course when conflict
does arise from said humanity mob cycle
100 treats the eyes of its viewers with
nothing short of stunning animation the
studio behind its adaptation is bones
who have an incredible resume under
their belt being responsible for Eureka
Seven my hero academia and both runs a
full metal alchemist but let's be real
were only going to want to remember
Brotherhood regardless but all of those
in Minds mump cycle 100 is without a
doubt some of bones as finest work
especially when it comes to action there
are fights especially in season two that
will just completely blow you away in a
triumph of 2d media but it's not just
the over-the-top stuff that they know
even subtle moments are handled with the
utmost of care and detail which is
essential especially in regard to the
more comedic portions because without
the care put into the animation many of
the jerks in the series could easily
fall flat but instead like everything
else they excel even so I suspect that
one of the biggest issues with getting
people into the series is going to be
its unique aesthetic I mean the first
time I watched the opening of season one
it felt like an overwhelming bombardment
of stuff you know I
sentient green clouds and broccoli
nothing makes sense and I'm not sure how
much I care for it to make sense but I
am so so glad I stuck with it just that
a little bit longer because Mom cycle
100 is capable of producing some damn
fine drama in addition to comedy and
action which was very unexpected for me
going into it it's actually pretty
amazing just how much you come to care
for these characters and I mean pretty
much all of them by the end of the
series I'm not sure if there was a
single recurring character no matter how
minor that I didn't have some sort of
investment in which is a huge credit to
the original author for crafting such
captivating figures as well as to bones
for doing them justice in animated form
so with all of this said does mump
psycho 100 have issues or is it indeed a
perfect series as I've probably made it
sound then I'm not sure looking back on
it I don't have any major issues from
character's story or animation
perspectives but I also think the series
gets a lot of leeway because of how
absurdly it presents itself so any fall
of poor storytelling that may be a
burden on more how shall we say serious
anime is very much forgiven in mob cycle
100 because it starts you off on the
premise that this series is weird enough
for anything to happen making it very
difficult to nitpick I mean if I was to
be really hyper critical I might cite
pacing as a minor issue because both
seasons follow a rather simple model
stacking the slice-of-life episodes into
the first half and then going all out on
plot development in the second half and
that's not necessarily a bad thing I
just personally prefer plot to be
ever-present and always feel like we're
progressing towards something and there
was some episodes where I finished
watching and went so yeah that was fun
but I do wish I'd moved along a bit more
but that is me being super super
critical it really is such a small issue
and one that may even only be exclusive
to me which is why I have no
reservations whatsoever about
recommending mump psycho 100 to any and
everyone it's not a huge commitment
either because early consists of two
seasons 13 episodes apiece with one ova
and another OVA to come I believe very
very easily digestible in no time at all
the biggest total once again is going to
be getting over the art style if you're
not accustomed to unique aesthetics but
it is well worth it because visually
there's so much in this series that can
be done that simply cannot be achieved
in the series it follows a more standard
artistic direction and really I just
can't remember the last time I had so
much fun with a series while still being
so invested in its characters and
overall story Mobe psycho 100 ticks all
the boxes for me it was a very pleasant
surprise because I started watching it
on a whim because I wasn't ready to
commit to something more serious
just yet and so I found myself with a
real gem and a fantastic experience and
I have
no doubt that you will find yourself in
very much the same situation but that
pretty much does it for why you should
watch mom psycho 100 if you enjoyed this
video and the content this channel
produced in general then please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and the patreon isn't quite yourself and
please do leave this video will like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on mob psycho 100 this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]
whoo oh my goodness it's like he's
singing a song let me make up his song
what would his song day wow so fabulous
fabulous but angry angry and fabulous
angry fabulous angry fabulous yeah